beauty standards we we talked a little
bit about this got brought up at the
beginning how does that tie into
femininity
sorry I'm very into this idea because I
do think it is one of the larger
intersections that just doesn't get very
discussed which is like I was talking
about before barriers and friction are
placed up around bodies and the fatter I
get the older I get the less people will
listen to me the less value I will have
for society so you know I'm already
starting out as a woman with no legs if
I had something on my face I have my
beauty that's one of my privileges I
have my whiteness that's one of my
privileges I used to have thinness and
now I'm getting fatter things are
changing and I think every single time
that we talk about feminism
um pretty privilege should be discussed
because we have these ideas if you your
skin tone is this if your hair is this
if your body looks like that it's about
whether or not you are given um an equal
opportunity based on what you look like
I saw it I think a lot of times the
women that complain about beauty
standards don't complain about them when
they got privileged when they were young
and attractive and thin so it's like
yeah you're complaining when the
privilege is gone but probably just but
privilege is invisible to those who have
it and women it's it's a privilege and
men don't turn 18 and get looks that we
get as a black woman uh one of the most
integral parts of the beauty
conversation has become has been
colorism
um I'm a dark-skinned black woman proud
of it and probably myself
for the most part I did not
why am I going to cry about this
I did not grow up thinking I was
beautiful because I was that that and I
think and the black and the black space
we have these conversations but I think
I'm kind of I'm glad I bring it up
because I think feminists actually
really should be part of the colorism
topic because colorism is not just
shade within being black it Shades
because they're again the beauty
standard is the closer to whiteness you
are the more beautiful you are I think
it's something that if more people in
different shades particularly white
women because of knowing that standard
and we work together on that then we'd
have a lot I think something we can
unify on but also something that we can
make strides in right now that I'm just
not singing It's only again it's that's
why people feel like you have to be a
black feminist because it's an it's a
topic that only really black feminists
are talking about because it deals with
being black
how how do beauty standards make you
feel
Morris
I mean kind of what you're saying um
Antonia as a black Latina woman in my
community right like I grew up and I was
ugly right like that's what I was
considered I was not considered
beautiful of feeling ugly but also being
told I was right had a lot to do with
what is believed in my community right
colorism is one of them and so to say
I'm gonna redefine Beauty for myself and
to say I own myself and I get to decide
what's beautiful right and I get to
decide what I want to wear and how I
want to wear it and I don't need to
right it's it's almost a repelling right
like I'm like no you know what I am
beautiful imma do what I want to do and
I'm gonna feel myself because if no one
else is going to feel me it's on me to
feel me too I gotta say though I did
grow up being referred to as very
beautiful for a woman with a disability
and that to me always fed this idea that
disability doesn't mean beautiful I am
in some form of exceptionalism which I
then had to keep up with forever so it's
like I got this thought as I started to
age like you can have no legs but you
better not [ __ ] get fat and so this
idea that like there are certain people
who are beautiful and certain people
aren't and that inherently holds value
is I think you know find it in yourself
yes and Jordan beauty standards are
toxic [ __ ] hierarchical nonsense and
I say that as someone who has spent over
a year collectively in my life in eating
disorder institutions because I have
tried to put my body through hellish
things to meet these beauty standards
which more often than not are not based
in reality they're typically Trends
they're created to push things they're
extremely useful for marketing but they
don't serve anyone's Health They don't
serve anyone's self-esteem they only act
to try and tell us that there's a
allegedly right way to have a body and
if you don't occupy that space and have
that body then you're a piece of [ __ ]
which is absolute nonsense and there are
way too many women and men in the world
who end up doing terrible things to
themselves because they fall into this
trap of thinking that you have to be
this way and if you aren't this way then
there's something inherently wrong at
your core which is nonsense you're
perfect the way you are right that's
literally the core of it you are perfect
the way you are and anyone who tries to
tell you otherwise is feeding into this
industry and is just they are not your
friend or looking out for you Leila oh
yeah I was going to say yeah Beauty in
the industry is exploitative
um but also we have to remember a lot of
the beauty standards are based around
Health what's perceived as health like
symmetry certain weights things like
that so there is that side where we have
to balance it and I think we're seeing
so much more representation which I
think is incredibly important well I
just think that like
if women really cared about beauty
standards like the obesity rate wouldn't
be what it is but it's trying to attain
the beauty standards I don't I mean I
just think like some people are more
attractive some people are less
attractive and that's just
you know where would I rate myself one
to time it's okay that's right that's
what I mean like I just think like some
people you are overweight you don't care
about beauty standards like the point is
that the beauty standard is thin right
ecd comes from men and women though yeah
you're right that's true but I'm saying
if women really wanted to fit the beauty
standard they would be thin I know I
just from my experience as well is
growing up again in a mostly white
neighborhood where but I was always
comparing myself to literally other
people who have a different body type
but I wasn't cons I was considered other
or to something because it didn't
conform to that body type when that same
body type became popular to with Kim
Kardashian the Kardashians who are
different right than me let's just say
our different skin color right and
there's a lot of animosity I I and a lot
of you know black communities of the
fact that
um when it was on black skin it was an
issue but when it was on Kim Kardashian
and the Kardashians it was a billion
dollar business
our time together has almost come to an
end
we sort of started talking about
feminism big picture we're gonna try
again is feminism dead
I think feminism is alive
and
I'm thankful to be a participant and
believer of it
I would say as far as the West goes I
think that feminism has been
cannibalized by other movements like
leftism like transgenderism so I think
feminism is very much alive and well I
think it takes different forms depending
on who you're talking to and that's not
necessarily A Bad Thing and as I've
defined in the beginning for me I use it
as a lens so I I don't think I'll ever
stop having it as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible